safety concerns in schools has been a
big topic of discussion over the past
year newly released documents showing a
big chunk of change going to campus
security upgrades but some parents say
they're worried to see this funding only
go to two schools sasha loftis joins us
tonight with more denise and brian these
documents released show a hefty price
for upcoming security upgrades but some
parents we spoke with say they're
concerned they're only focused on those
two campuses
it is very concerning camilla bywaters
is worried about what's to come as a
ccsd parent parents want to know that
their children are safe she spoke out
during thursday's regular board meeting
after information on emergency security
funding for schools was released
documents show scheduled upgrades at el
dorado high school will cost just over
26 million dollars with the majority of
that money going to secure campus
fencing cctv camera upgrades a single
entry door and an alert system clark
high school will see similar changes to
the tune of about 100 thousand bucks
increasing safety measures for one
school ccsd calls this a life safety
necessity citing violent events like the
recent attack and sexual assault on an
eldorado teacher but speaking as a local
advocate for equity bywaters says all
southern nevada schools deserve the same
treatment it is important that funding
is directed towards safety that is not a
question or an argument but it also
needs to be equitable across our
district so every student can feel
comfortable in the classroom how can we
support
all schools and ensuring that all
students all staff all teachers have
safe schools to come to
now ccsd documents also added that each
school building has unique needs based
on infrastructure and costs will vary
throughout the district we did ask for
an itemized list for upgrades and
expenses but the district says they are
keeping that confidential at this time
brian